it is a show that celebrates the legacy
of the fame brother sister Duo the
Carpenters and it's the world's only
authentic Carpenter's tribute insight
and sound welcome the sponsors of this
next segment Sally Olson and Ned Mills
from the Carpenters Legacy welcome you
two yeah thank you I feel like I'm
sitting next to the Carpenters I mean
this is absolutely incredible tell us a
little bit about the show it's it's just
all of their biggest hits right that's
right um do you want to go ahead yeah
it's it's a recreation from the
Carpenters 1976 UK tour and so we're one
of the only acts we actually perform in
character I'm probably only Richard
that's out there well now you're holding
a record and that is that your record of
that Recreation it is it sure is and
yeah we decided to keep everything
vintage retro and authentic this is a
vinyl album that they came up with and
for the more modern fans we have a
compact disc as well so well tell us
about the what what makes this project
so unique yeah well what makes this one
particularly special is not only are we
recreating their hits we took one of
their biggest hits and gave it a Fresh
coat of paint we're taking Superstar and
Sally is singing it in Spanish oh wow
and so we're adding a nice little Latin
beer a reggaeton we put in it added a
Conga player and we have a music video
that's right it's and it's on Vivo yeah
yeah we definitely need to look that up
oh I'm excited to see that Sally how do
people get this album or the CD if
they're interested they can go to our
website that's carpenterslegacy.com and
there's information on how to order the
vinyl record or the CD on our website or
they can come to our show at the Modern
showrooms and we have it available there
after the show yeah definitely need to
check this out so the modern showroom at
the Alexis Park you guys have been doing
shows that your 200th show is coming up
congratulations yeah thank you yeah if
people are interested in going what can
they expect from the night is it is it
just one of those uh Throwbacks where
it's going to remind you of your
childhood or listening with your parents
to the Carpenters is that what we can
expect absolutely when we do these type
of shows we have some people that are
actually crying at the end saying you
played our wedding song you know and
it's very it's very emotional and modern
showrooms were very uh honored to be
there because it brings back from the
days of classic Vegas in an intimate
Cabaret space now what is the the
reaction you get most from the audience
when you see them most people say that
it's a really emotional experience for
them and it takes them on a trip down
memory lane and like what Ned said for a
lot of people it's memories of their
wedding because so many people had close
to you or We've Only Just Begun as
wedding songs even for all we know and
for some people it's memories of being a
young kid and that's what their parents
had on so just really a lot of really
special memories and associations for
people with this music honestly just
sitting next to you guys I'm getting the
carpenter Vibes big time and I I feel
like I'm getting a little emotional too
because it reminds me of my parents and
what they listen to yeah cannot wait to
see this show it sounds incredible uh
thank you to Carpenter's Legacy for
sponsoring this segment again if you
want tickets their shows are at the
Modern showrooms at Alexis Park Resort
Hotel and if you want more information
visit carpenters.legacy.com